all right thanks i'm going to talk about
something not completely unrelated i'm
going to ask sort of a basic question in
economics but i'm going to ask it
through the lens of learning theory so
when do prices coordinate markets and
this is joint work with my excellent
colleagues at penn and
jamie's making a cameo
also a colleague of them yes
but you're the only one making the cameo
so i want to just sort of reflect for a
moment
on um
you know a remarkable fact that you know
we all reflect on a lot uh
prices are really remarkable objects
because
markets are decentralized and
nevertheless prices serve as a summary
statistic
we all go out we interact with the world
through prices we optimize our own
individual utility functions we buy what
we like given the prices
and by and large things seem to work out
pretty well markets clear supply is
approximately equal to demand and
the resulting allocation is pretty good
okay so let's just sort of think for a
moment about what the theory tells us
about why this might be in a in a
discrete allocation problem
okay so
i want to talk about a particular you
know simple object commodity market
which i'm going to think of as k types
of indivisible goods each of which has
some supply
okay and there's going to be a set of
buyers and each is going to have some
valuation function which maps bundles of
goods to a real number how much they
like that good
okay an allocation is just a function
mapping buyers to some bundle of goods
now
when facing prices what are people going
to do well sort of a
minimal kind of assumption is that
they're going to be self-interested and
they're going to buy something in their
demand set okay the demand set of a
buyer at some price p is just the set of
bundles that maximizes his value for the
bundle minus the price he'd have to pay
to buy it okay and and
there might be you know ties there might
be many things in the demand set of a
buyer at a particular price factor and
i'm not going to assume anything about
how buyers are going to break ties just
that they'll
buy something in their demand set
okay
so
so you know a classic you know pricing
object in this world is a walrasian
equilibrium so just to remind us what
that is
a set of prices in this setting form a
while racing equilibrium
if they can be paired with some
allocation that satisfies the following
three properties
okay so first
uh every
buyer should be allocated something that
is in his demand set it should be some
most demanded bundle of goods given the
prices
and
the allocation should actually be
feasible that is the number of copies of
each good that are allocated should not
exceed the supply
and finally
the only case in which the number of
copies of a good that are allocated that
can be strictly less than the supply
that the only time that can happen is if
the price of the good is zero if those
three conditions are satisfied then we
can say that
the price vector together with this
allocation form a wall racing
equilibrium
and these are these are remarkable
objects so again to remind you of how
remarkable these are
um what the first welfare theorem tells
us is if such an object exists even
though
you know what rice and equilibrium is
sort of defined as individuals you know
buying things in their demand set you
know so it's
optimizing their individual utilities
the resulting allocation has to be
optimal
and
they actually these things do exist in a
wide or relatively wide setting at least
if buyers have uh
preferences that are in the
gross substitutes class
and they're not hard to find they're
sort of natural ascending price auction
dynamics like kelso crawford that
converge to them
and in fact there's many such prices but
uh they form a lattice but
when i talk about them now i'm gonna
focus on the minimal wall racing
equilibrium prices and these are focal
for a number of reasons
both because ascending price auction
dynamics tend to converge to the minimal
while racing equilibrium prices and
because in
you know say for unit demand buyers
these things correspond to vcg prices
what do you mean by minimum
so the
prices form a lattice so you can talk
about the minimal price vector which is
coordinate wise minimal among all wall
racing equilibrium price factors but
it's not not important
okay
so it's tempting to to look at this
classical theory and and summarize it as
prices optimally coordinate a large
class of markets look at these prices
you know buy the stuff you want and
things work out the welfare is optimal
and supply equals demand
and what i want to focus on is two
possible um
holes in this interpretation and i want
to see to what extent we can use the
tools of learning theory to fix these
holes
so one problem with this interpretation
is that
the prices do not necessarily coordinate
the market that is while racing
equilibrium is is defined as a pricing
paired with an allocation because fixing
the prices there's not necessarily a
unique bundle in every buyer's demand
set
and in fact
although we know there is some way for
each buyer to pick some bundle in his
demand set that will result in supply
equaling demand and welfare being
maximized uh they might need to
break ties in a coordinated way in a
something in a way that the prices do
not themselves coordinate okay just to
give you sort of a cartoon of how this
can happen
suppose we've got n buyers and then
goods and buyer i is indifferent between
good i and good one and has value zero
for all of the other goods
for example
okay
and this in this toy example the minimal
wall racing equilibrium prices really
contain very little information to
coordinate the market they're all zero
and at these prices every buyer remains
indifferent between
good eye and good one okay the only way
to coordinate an optimal allocation is
for
buyer eye to buy good eye but if say
they break ties randomly half of them
will attempt to buy good one they'll be
horrific over demand
since you mentioned ascending price
options wouldn't this would be one way
to coordinate buyers so yes good so i'll
get to this so
the prices themselves here are not a
coordinating signal if you actually
participate in a dynamic like kelso
crawford
the history it's true the history of
your coordination the history of your
participation in the auction serves as a
coordinating device but that'll be the
second thing i'm going to get to
okay
but and and i want to point out that you
know you could come up with a
distribution over instances where you
know say the distinguished good is
chosen at random and then any tie
breaking rule that the players used that
was independent of the other buyers
would result in expected over demand and
over two for this kid and the prices
here are doing very little to coordinate
this make sense this example
so i forgot to mention but the first
buyer here is also an economist
and
um
the objects he says okay i mean you can
you can cook up examples in which
coordination is a is a problem but but
this seems non-generic there are
you know lots of ties here and what what
this buyer means by his objection is
that perhaps if the values are drawn
from a sufficiently smooth distribution
perhaps then you know maybe with
probability one there are no
indifferences at the
minimal well racing equilibrium prices
maybe somehow we never expect to see
indifferences and this is something that
can only happen if you're a computer
scientist obsessed with worst-case
measures
but that's not true unfortunately so
it's not too hard to see that there will
always be indifferences at the wall race
at the minimal wall racing equilibrium
prices it's not too surprising
equilibria tend to induce indifferences
but suppose there weren't by that i mean
um
sorry suppose um suppose you had a
market where there were no indifferences
okay so what that means is that
a good j
is demanded by some buyer i if and only
if buyer i is the one who's supposed to
get good j in the optimal allocation
well in that case i could take any
non-zero price and i could lower it by
epsilon and i'd still have a wall racing
equilibrium but that would contradict
minimality okay so whenever we've got
minimal wall racing equilibrium prices
we always have indifferences and and
generosity is somehow not going to save
us from this fact
now
clearly if i'm going to tell a story in
which prices alone serve to coordinate
markets we're going to need to make some
kind of genericity assumption because
the example i showed you
the prices just don't coordinate the
market
but what i want to point out is that we
need to approach this by considering
approximation we cannot appeal to
genericity simply to remove the problem
altogether
so so here's the second problem
so where do the prices come from and
azelia pointed out
we do have stories for this there are
ascending price auction dynamics that
converge to these prices and in fact if
you participate in these dynamics they
also solve the coordination problem for
you they're ascending price auctions and
the bundle of goods you're supposed to
get are the last bundle you bid on you
bid on okay
but in practice
you know when i when i walk around
berkeley i do not participate in
ascending price auctions um
somehow the
the prices are not a function of my
direct participation
okay
so in practice we sort of imagine that
prices must be encoding distributional
information about the market
but because
they're because they're not a function
of my participation we cannot rely on
sort of the history my memory of
participating in some ascending price
auction to serve as the coordination
device
okay
so
this also brings up questions if we're
if we're going to assert the prices are
encoding distributional information this
brings up questions of the sort that tim
just talked about how much
distributional information is necessary
how many samples do i need to see from
some population before i can be
confident that the prices i've got are
pretty good for the distribution not for
the fixed population
and of course in a model like this
the prices i'm using since they
weren't computed as a function of the
people actually buying the goods
are only going to be sort of approximate
equilibrium prices which might just
exacerbate the coordination problem okay
so we need some theory maybe of how
approximate equilibrium prices work and
are learned
so here's the model we're studying in
this work okay we've got a commodity
market we've got k types of goods and
each has some supply
and we've got some unknown distribution
over bidder valuations
and
n bidders and buyers are sampled iid
from this distribution
and
i'm going to assume that the market is
going to equilibrate at the minimal wall
racing equilibrium prices uh
computed you know
defined by the market including these
end bidders i'm agnostic to how this
happens perhaps they actually do
participate in a kelso crawford-like
dynamic
but the important point is these prices
are not going to be used to sell goods
to these buyers instead
once the prices are fixed a new sample
of n buyers is drawn from the same
distribution
and these buyers have no information to
coordinate them other than their price
so at this point the buyers are going to
buy
arbitrary bundles in their demand set
given the prices i'm going to assume
nothing about how ties are broken it
could be worst case
and the question is
well how much over demand do we expect
and what kind of welfare do we expect in
the resulting allocation
and what do these things depend on do
they depend on the particulars of the
distribution
do they depend on somehow the complexity
of buyer valuation functions or the
number of buyers or the number of goods
okay
and
to answer this question
sort of taking the perspective of
learning theory there's really two cross
two separate questions i need to answer
the first is when do the exact
equilibrium prices induce little over
demand on the market for which they were
computed and by analogy to machine
learning this is asking when is the
training error small when can i expect
low over demand for the prices fit
specifically to a market
and remember from the example i showed
you the answer is not always we need
some
we'll need some genericity condition and
we'll need to talk about it in terms of
approximation
and the second question is how well the
equilibrium prices that are computed on
a particular sample
generalized to new buyers drawn from the
same distribution and again by analogy
to learning theory this is the
analog of generalization error
okay and how much data is needed
so let's think about the first question
and for the purposes of the talk let me
tell you just about unit demand
buyers although in the paper and i'll
mention at the end we actually handle
essentially up to gross substitutes
okay but unit demand buyers are real
simple they just want one item and
therefore their valuation functions can
be described each buyer just has sort of
k real numbers describing his valuation
function how much he likes each good
and the genericity condition we're going
to ask for here in this case is also
extremely simple
and it's essentially going to say that
these numbers which specify the
valuations of the bidders
should be linearly independent over the
integers meaning if i take some linear
combination of these numbers with
integer coefficients
and the linear combination sums to zero
the only way that can happen is if all
of the coefficients are zero and i don't
even need linear combinations over the
integers it suffices to have this where
the coefficients can be minus one zero
and one what's the generosity condition
i'm going to ask for remember we need
some condition if over demand is going
to be low
and just a note on this assumption
it does imply that the welfare optimal
allocation is unique and that's
important because if there are multiple
optimal allocations they will all be
supported by the any equilibrium price
vector and so you'll get indifferences
and it's satisfied with probability one
for any continuous perturbation of the
valuations
so maybe i'm justified in calling it a
generosity assumption
okay and the theorem
in this simple case
is that if we've got valuations that
satisfy this genericity assumption and
we've got the exact minimal
well-received equilibrium prices on this
market that is computed with respect to
the actual bidders
then although there will be some over
demands it will be as low as possible
and the number of people who demand each
good
will be no more than one more than the
supply of the good
in particular no matter how people break
ties with no assumptions on how they
break ties although there will be
indifferences the over demand on any
good will be at most one and therefore
it will become a diminishing fraction of
the total supply as the supply grows
large
okay so the proof for unit demand is
simple enough to show you
so let's fix the optimal allocation
which is unique and fix the minimal well
racing equilibrium prices and i want to
think about a graph okay the vertices
are going to correspond to the goods so
there's k vertices
and there will be an edge between good j
and good j prime
if there's some buyer i
who is assigned in the optimal
allocation good j
but who also has good j prime in his
demand set so the edges represent
indifferences
so we've got a graph like this the
vertices are goods the edges are buyers
and the first step i just want to make a
series of simple observations about this
graph the first observation is the graph
has to be a cyclic
because if it's not
players could swap allocations around a
cycle they'd all still be getting a most
demanded good the supply would still
equal demand and by the first welfare
theorem this would be a different
optimal allocation which would
contradict the uniqueness of the optimal
allocation
okay so the graph didn't look like this
that edge wasn't there the graph has to
be acyclic
and since the graph is acyclic i might
as well topologically sort it and rename
the vertices in order
okay and the first vertex is going to
have in degree zero since it's a
topological sort
the next observation is any good that
has in degree zero and we know there's
at least one of them
has to have price zero
that's not too hard to see if it didn't
you know i could just lower the price by
a little bit and uh i'd still have wall
racing equilibrium prices which would
contradict minimality because there's
nobody who
isn't getting the good but is
indifferent to it
okay so anything within degree zero has
price zero
and so i claim
any price in the minimum wall racing
price vector can be written as a linear
combination of buyer valuations
where
these are valuations for goods that come
earlier in the topological sort
than good j does
okay the base case as well if the
price is zero then we're done
and if the price is not zero remember we
know it's got to have in-degree at least
one
okay so if the price is bigger than zero
there's some buyer i
who's receiving a good in the optimal
allocation earlier in the ordering
but is indifference between that good
and good j
okay
and we can write down that in difference
condition his value minus price for the
good he's receiving is equal to his
value minus price for good j that's what
it means for him to be indifferent and
just rewriting this we can write good j
as a function of his value for these two
goods plus the price of good j prime and
just apply our inductive assumption to
the price of good j prime which is
earlier in the ordering
okay and so we're almost done the final
claim which is what we want to prove in
the end is that all goods in this graph
have in degree at most one or the in
degree of the
uh graph represents the demand of the
good beyond its supply
and suppose not that's i suppose there
was some good that had in degree two
then there are two buyers i and i prime
who are both indifferent to this good
and some good earlier in the ordering
okay
so we've got two different indifference
conditions
but both of them have
the price of good j in them
so we can just solve for these two
different expressions for the price of
good j and subtract them from one
another they equal zero
okay but we're going to get a linear
combination of valuations that violates
our generosity condition so that's it
oh
so remember this was sort of step one of
the argument this was the analog of
asking for a condition under which
training error was small
but we've got to talk about
generalization error as well
let me just mention that
the proof is very simple that's what i
showed you for unit demand valuations
but our result is not limited to that so
we've got a similar genericity condition
and a substantially more complicated
argument it's good to have graduate
students
that guarantees the same result maximum
over demand at most one
for the class of what are called metroid
based valuations these are a class
evaluations that has some nice structure
you can work with to talk about this
indifference graph and in fact is
conjecture these are these valuations
are a subset of gross substitute
valuations and it's in fact conjectured
but to be equal to growth substitutes
okay so modulo this unproven conjecture
that matroid-based valuations are equal
to gross substitutes valuations uh the
result is fully general in the sense
that it holds for the largest class
evaluation functions for which wall
racing equilibrium prices are guaranteed
to exist
so let's sort of tackle the second
question now okay we've got some
condition
under which exact equilibrium prices
when computed on a population
induce low over demand that's pretty
good that means we can at least fit good
prices to a sample if we get to compute
the price as a function of that sample
but
we also need to ask
how well will these prices generalize in
terms of
both over demand and welfare if we use
the same prices on a new population
okay
okay so
you know
and now we're going to get a little bit
closer to tim's talk we're going to have
to talk about
uniform convergence over some class of
functions and the class is the question
is what class of functions do we want to
talk about
so let's define some functions
okay
fix some tie-breaking rule it can be
arbitrary but fix the tie-breaking rule
that the players are going to use and it
maybe it can be even be different for
every player
to select bundles in their
demand set when their demand set is not
unique
i just want to give a name
to the
bundle that buyer i will select facing
prices p according to this tiebreaking
rule when he faces prices p which bundle
in the demand set he'll buy
okay
sorry that's a deterministic sync over
there uh let's say it's deterministic
nothing particularly changes if it's a
randomized rule well let's say it's
deterministic
okay and i just want to use this to
define a function okay fixing price is p
let me define this function
parameterized by p
to be the function that takes as input
evaluation function
vi
and just tells me what bundle of goods
a buyer with valuation vi is going to
attempt to buy when he faces prices p
okay defining the function
and
okay so the the range of this function
is bundles
and now let me define sort of a
one-dimensional projection of this
function i'll call it
d for demand
and it's going to be parameterized both
by a price vector and by a good j
and what it's going to tell me is given
as input evaluation function
will a buyer with valuation function vi
by good j or not
okay this function takes value 1 if he
will choose a bundle that has good j in
it and value 0 otherwise
and the reason this is a good function
to think about is because
given a distribution over valuation
functions and a particular price vector
i'm going to use
the expected demand for a good j given
the price is p is just n
times the expected value of this
function when i evaluate the expectation
over valuation functions drawn from the
distribution
so it's going to be it's going to
suffice for us to obtain uniform
convergence
of the empirical averages
of these functions the class of
functions which map
valuation functions to the indicator of
whether a buyer with that valuation
function will buy a good j or not
and this class of functions is
parameterized by price vectors so the
class includes sort of uncountably many
functions one for each price vector
it's going to suffice for us to obtain
uniform convergence of the empirical
averages overall this set of functions
to their expectations
the reason is because
if we can do that then with high
probability
over two draws
of n bitters from the same distribution
we'll know that for every price vector
demand will be similar on both of these
two samples and in particular since it
holds for every price vector it will
hold for the minimal well racing prices
computed on the first sample and subject
to the genericity condition we know that
in that case the demand might mustache
the over demand must actually be small
yeah the randomness here is not over the
tie breaking rule like there's no
there's no news that's right here for
the purposes of the talk let's assume
the tie breaking rule is deterministic
the randomness is entirely you said you
fixed the tie breaking rules you're
fixing it for training and test
basically that's right
and the randomness is over the draws
from the valuation function
so this sort of
uh goes back to a question shannon asked
in tim's
talk there's a relationship between
learning and uniform convergence okay
it's
sufficient to obtain
sufficient to obtain uniform convergence
uniform convergence is sufficient for
learning but it is not necessary when
you're in a general learning setting
okay but it happens that if the function
you're trying to learn is a
one-dimensional boolean valued function
then the number of samples you need in
order to learn meaning the number of
samples you need in order to reliably
predict the outcome of a function is
exactly equal to the number of samples
you need to obtain uniform convergence
over the class of functions you're
learning over
okay
so the argument we make goes through the
following diagram
we show that these functions f which map
valuation functions to bundle
predictions these are not boolean
learning functions
these are learnable with k over epsilon
samples this is in fact not enough to
obtain uniform convergence over this
class of functions
but
learning these functions predicting the
bundle predictions is sufficient
to
also learn these sort of lower
dimensional functions which
just ask you to predict is a buyer going
to buy good one or not because if i can
accurately predict the whole bundle he's
going to buy i can also tell you if he's
going to buy a good one or not
and so i know these classes are fun this
class of functions is also learnable
with k over epsilon samples
and since that's a boolean class of
functions
uh k over epsilon samples is enough for
uniform convergence
so i i don't have
much time so i won't go through the
details but the
learning results we use when we're
trying to learn this function in bundle
space has to do with this technique of
of compression bounds that's sort of a
classical technique that doesn't require
uniform convergence but uh
isn't i think as well known in our
community
and it turns out that uh using a
very nice learning results by danielle
and shalev schwartz that was first used
brought to our attention in economic
context by a paper of uh balkan at all
and ruta's in the audience i don't know
if any of the others are
using this technique you can relatively
straightforwardly argue that
this class of functions mapping
prices to bundles is compressible okay
this is a really you know if you haven't
read this paper you should so it really
it's a nice
class of functions from an economic
context that turns out to be easily
learnable
and so the result is these functions are
learnable
and we get uniform convergence with only
k over epsilon samples
okay so skipping to the punch line
the total demand for any good in the end
on the new samples drawn from the
distribution
is with high probability going to be a
within a one plus or minus epsilon
factor of the supply
under the condition that the supply is
larger than k the number of types of
goods over epsilon squared okay so in
order for these prices to actually work
well you need the market to be somewhat
large the supply of the goods got to be
you know
kind of big relative to the number of
kinds of goods but but not you know not
too big
and you've got to go that was for over
demand you've got to go through a
similar argument for welfare welfare
doesn't allow you to do this trick of
mapping onto a boolean class of
functions because welfare is sort of
real valued you've got to directly go
through some argument bounding
pseudo-dimension which i want were you
with
but you get a similar punchline for
welfare and so i'd like to end the talk
uh thanking our sponsors ricky noticed
that
delta actually has an ad campaign that's
remarkably similar to the title of this
workshop and so i assume this is where
our sponsorship is coming from
yes
you probably said this
so i apologize but i was wondering what
you want to focus on minimum while
raising prices
um
so that good so
to ask these questions you do have to
fix some well where i see in price
factor i don't want you to pick among
the set of wall racing prices as a
function of the actual realized
valuations that would be one way to try
to coordinate people but
it would sort of be cheating
uh and among the set of wall racing
price factors i sort of view the minimal
ones as being focal because that's what
these
ascending price dynamics converge to but
you could ask the same question for
other polaris and price factors and i
don't know the extent to which all of
these results generalize
so suppose i think the price is
a kind of generic way
then does that do anything to resolve
the resolve this problem it probably
depends on what you mean pick the prices
in a generic way
certainly if you're allowed to pick the
prices as a function of the people
you're going to sell to
then it turns out that if the max
welfare allocation is unique there is a
way you can pick the prices that will
result in no indifferences but somehow
this is solving the coordination problem
by a centralized planner who's got
access to the evaluation functions of
the people he's actually selling to
because you've got to compute these
things as a function of the values if
you do not have access to the values of
the
players you're actually selling to then
i don't know any way
in which you can sort of generically
pick prices that will resolve this
problem but that's an interesting
question
i guess that's maybe segwaying
from what you just said is in those
cases where
your number of samples is too low for
prices to work well
yeah good question i mean our results
are sort of tight in that the vc
dimension
the the number of samples you actually
need for uniform convergence is also at
least the quantity i wrote down so
you know if if the number of samples is
too low then
i'm not sure exactly why you would
necessarily expect these prices to
coordinate the market without some some
extra assumption or some extra your
result basically match that that is
whenever you can learn you can actually
find a price mechanism that would that
that would achieve anymore yeah i think
okay
so that that in itself is interesting
sure uh i mean what if you have just a
little bit less
sample like is there a smooth
deterioration here like you
you know you got
not quite enough simple to learn it
right but
maybe half as many or something well so
remember when i so maybe i'm
misunderstanding the question but the
bound i gave was parameterized by
epsilon i said if you want to get within
you know one plus or minus epsilon
factor of the supply
then you need k over epsilon squared
samples but alternatively like i said
here's the number of samples you you
have i'll solve for epsilon this is how
well you do
all right thank you